على المتحدث بسم الله كريم لاند متر
بيسكوف ان روسيا ممثله في قمه مجموعه ال
20 على مستوى عال بشخص وزير الخارجيه
سيرجي لبروف كشف بيسكوف انا لافروف يتواصل
مع دائره كبيره من المشاركين في القمه
واشار الى ان روسيا على استعداد للتواصل
مع كل من لديه رغبه لذلك بشان غياب الرئيس
بوتين عن القمه قال بيسكو ان ظروفه لي على
بوتن اولويه بقائه في روسيا لذلك تم اتخاذ
قرار ان تشارك موسكو على مستوى وزير
الخارجيه وفي شان اخر نفا وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سر جاي لابروف الذي يرى السوافذ
بلاده الى قمه ال 20 تقارير التي تحدثت عن
نقله الى المستشفى بسبب حاله مرضيه تتعلق
بالقلب وكانت وكاله بريس نقلت عن مسؤولينا
اندونيسيين قولهم انا لامروف نقل الى
المستشفى بعد وصوله الى جزيره بالي قال
لافرو في النصيحه فييين الغربيين يكتبون
كذبا على مدى عشر سنوات مضيفا ان هذا
النوع من الالعاب ليس جديدا في الساحه
السياسيه واضاف ان صحفيين الغربيين بحاجه
الى ان يكونوا اكثر صدقا وان يكتبوا
الحقيقه من جهته اعلن حاكم جزيره جبال
الاندونيسيه حيث تعقد قمه العشرين انا
لابروف بصحه جيده وكان في المستشفى لاجراء
فحص طبيا
انا من بالي في اندونيسيا مراسل الجزيره
زور الشوج ومدير مكتبنا في موسكو اهلا بك
بعد كل اللقطه الذي احاط به الوضع الصحي
لوزير الخارجيه الروسيه بروف
ما الذي يقوله الوفد الروسي بخصوص ما
يحمله الى هذه القمه ولقاءاته المرتقبه
نعم في البدايه اذا تحدثنا عن اللقط الذي
جرى والذي تم نشره من بعض وسائل الاعلام
الاجنبيه حاول الاجانب الروسي ان يتعامل
مع الموضوع بنوع من السخريه وربما
الفيديوهات التي نشرتها المتحدثه باسم
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه كافيه لتوضيح
الراديو الروسي وانه في اطار محاوله جعل
روسيا معزوله هنا وابعاد
الوفود التي ترغب بها التواصل معها ولكن
اذا طلقنا الى ربما المرحله الجديده هناك
ترقب من الخطاب الذي سيقيه غدا
انه فيها الكل يتوقع انه بعد او خلال
القاء اللقاء الخطاب يمكن ان يغادر همم
تصفيفه من روسيا باعدائها بادول الغربيه
مجتمعه همم القاعه اثناء القائمه همم
الكلمه ولكن بحسب وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
من المرتقب ان يقدم الظروف تصورات
المتعلقه بدرجه الاولى بمسائل التسويه
الاقتصاديه بمسائل الخروج من الازمه
الاقتصاديه والركود الذي يمكن ان يصيب
قطاعات كبيره في اقتصادات العالم الذي
يتضرر براي موسكو بدرجه الاولى من سياسه
المنافسه غير النزيهه المرتبطه بالعقوبات
التي تفرضها الدول الغربيه وعلى راسها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بحق المنافسين
او بتجاه المنافسين الاقتصاديين
والمنافسين السياسيين والاستراتيجيين في
العالم كما علمنا ايضا سيقوم للروب بتقديم
همم بشكل رسمي الى المجتمع الدولي تفاصيل
المبادره الروسيه لانشاء مركز توزيع
الدولي للغاز على الاراضي همم
الملامح الواسعه لهذا المشروع الذي يبدو
على الاقل بما يتسرب بانه سيكون مفتوحا
ليس فقط امام الغاز الروسي وانما امام كل
الدول المنتجه همم لالغاز من اجل ان يتم
همم التحكم باسعار الطاقه بعيدا عن
المضاربات في قالت الان تتضرر منها كثير
من قبل العالم ولكن من الواضح ان الاجانب
الروسي يريد ان يركز بدرجه الاولى على
الجوانب الاقتصاديه وليست سياسيه ومن هنا
ربما يبرز الموقف الروسي بانه سيعرض اي
همم بيان يمكن ان يتهم روسيا او يجب روسيا
في مساله حربها في اوكرانيا
شكرا جزيلا لك